so Batman's son just created a whole
universe and it's amazing check this out
so this is the conclusion for deceased
War of the undead Gods just one of the
best stories that DC Comics has released
in the last like five years it's
absolutely phenomenal so for those of
you guys who are catching up with us at
this point at the end it's now time to
go to war with aerobos now I will make
sense of everything that's going on in
case you're joining us for the very
first time but again this is fantastic
because with everybody having previously
succumbed to the anti-life virus which
is really this story stand in for a
zombie virus if we want to call it what
it is that you have all these people
that are basically snapping back right
they're all basically coming back to
normal but here's the kicker remember
Erebus is the one behind all of this
which is to say the anti-life virus
originated with him it was dark side at
the very beginning of the story of
deceased itself basically tapping into
the power of Erebus without really
understanding what it was that he was
doing to put this in more practical
terms what Darkseid did is he took a
drop of ink and he put it in a glass of
water it just changed everything right
that's literally what he did that drop
of ink of course being the power or the
influence of Erebus to basically affect
and destroy this whole really the whole
universe to be honest because everybody
Across the Universe was infected here
but of course with like Supergirl Kara
zorrell coming back this is one of the
crueler moments because remember in the
DC story when she was shot to Earth she
didn't actually go to earth like she
does in the main DC Universe instead she
went to the realm of the new gods and
was immediately attacked and turned into
a zombie and so that's why here when she
initially comes across Superman her
initial response is no there's no way
you're Superman Kalel is a baby because
up to this point she never met him I
remember Supergirl comes from Argo City
it was one of the last surviving cities
when Krypton was destroyed but Superman
was a baby by the time Krypton died so
of course given time dilation and aging
differences and so on and so forth
that's why he's basically aged up here
so for her it's coming across someone
from Krypton who survived outside of
herself but not the person that she
recalls now the bigger takeaway from
this and this is one of the bigger
things that goes on here there's two
massive shifts that go on the first is
that dark side joins the heroes now one
of the reasons why this happens even
though Darkseid won't readily admit it
is because he needs the heroes right and
in fact dartside is going to have this
amazing moment here in a little while
but like he needs the heroes right so
it's kind of like there's no way for him
to defeat erebos on his own but the
other thing that goes on here is the
black racer joins in now remember the
black racer is one of the many aspects
of death that exists in DC Comics and so
having all these Heavy Hitters on their
sides these are some of the most
powerful beings to ever exist in DC
Comics what's so funny is that the
solution for everything comes from
Damian Wayne the Son of Batman now of
course Bruce Wayne for those of you guys
who are just joining us he died at the
very beginning of deceased Bruce Wayne
Dick Grayson Tim Drake they're all dead
right Damian Wayne is the only real
surviving member of the immediate bat
family which is to say basically like
anybody who played the role of Robin
he's the only surviving person but he
ends up meeting with the black racer and
he says my father and my brothers taught
me to respect all life but before I was
Batman before I was Robin I was an
assassin I was raised to look for
weaknesses now what he's talking about
here for all the new folks is remember
during Grant Morrison's Batman run
Damien Wayne was initially introduced as
basically being the Son of Batman that
he never knew about that through some
pretty shady stuff Talia al Ghul gave
birth to Damien and then Damien being
trained by Talia al Ghul and her ilk was
just dropped up on the doorstep of
Batman and was like now he's yours to
raise so Bruce Wayne had to teach Damien
that he can't just kill anybody who
commits a crime it was a great story
it's called Batman and Son it was a
great story Grant Morrison's run on
Batman is phenomenal and we'll probably
cover it right beyond what we've done
already but it was a great story the
bigger thing here though is that when
Damien talks about this he was an
assassin but that's what he says I've
been thinking about how to take the
fight to the source
Erebus is a primordial deity it's the
personification of dark the only thing
that can destroy the dark is light
Erebus is anti-life and I have an idea I
want you to tell me if it will work I
want you to confirm this and I can end
this being I'd like your help to do so
and so this is an important distinction
to understand
Erebus is about as close as DC Comics
gets to what is by all standards of
measurement a cosmic entity in Marvel
Comics right a primordial being a being
that's been around since the beginning
of everything in existence and
represents a particular concept but of
course following this Damien goes to
meet with Cyborg and they have this bit
of a conversation right Damian Wayne
kind of spills the beans to cyborg in
terms of what his plan is and then they
call together all the surviving
superheroes and super villains because
remember in this conflict there are no
heroes and villains anymore right
there's not really like the good guys
fighting the bad guys or anything along
those lines it's just the survivors and
the dead and so with this great big huge
conversation that goes on what they
realize is that in order to act access
aerobos they have to go through what's
called a doom tube the problem with this
is the only way to pass through a doom
tube is to be dead and so in order to
pull that off what they're going to do
is literally die right they're going to
basically have their hearts shut down
and that in the moment when they've
passed they're going to move through the
Doom tube and then arrive at aerobos and
to do that they're gonna bring War World
now this is cool right because War World
historically speaking in DC Comics has
just quite literally been exactly what
it sounds like a war-torn world it's ran
by Mongol it's basically a place where
you have like endless gladiatorial
fights it's an amazing concept right
it's a really really cool Concept in DC
now of course Dark Side chimes in and
goes as far as to say like dark side
will face Erebus right of course you
know then Guy Gardner chimes in and Guy
Garner basically gets uh he gets smacked
around a bit for his troubles the other
part of this though is they reveal that
in order to gain the attention of Erebus
they need forces powerful enough to
effectively distract him and so we're
dark slides on board they even turned to
the God of War Aries now of course Ares
ever one of the more interesting
characters in DC Comics and for reasons
that I'll never fully understand Tom
Taylor loves this guy like every story
he does has the God of War Aries in some
capacity he loves this dude and I don't
blame him right under any normal
circumstance Aries is a horse like this
guy is an absolute he's literally the
God of War like he's just one of the
coolest characters in DC but despite all
the power that he has he just tells them
Point Blank I'm not going in there to
fight Airbus that's a suicide mission
like I'm not going in there to do that
I'm just gonna stand back and watch and
that's when Cassie Sands Mark chimes in
and calls him a coward but she literally
calls Ares the god of war a coward to
his face right she was like there's a
battle to be fought and your plan is to
hide from it right and where his
response is Aries does not hide the
response of Lois right stepping in Lois
Lane why she steps in she's like really
where were you when my son was standing
between this planet and Annihilation
right and even the black racers chimes
in and says if you face Erebus tomorrow
old God you will not be alone I will be
beside you death has always followed war
and so it's really kind of cornering
Aries the God of War and basically
making him fulfill his role so
ultimately he ends up joining in right
it's kind of like okay fine look I'll do
it then right like I'll go ahead and do
this thing now what also complicates
things a little bit is that during the
time when deceased was happening you
actually saw alliances and even romances
forming where they normally never would
have one of the romances that formed was
between Damian Wayne and Cassie which if
I'm being honest with you guys I kind of
hope this becomes a main DC Universe
thing I don't actually know that's going
on right now I'm not current with the
robin series and Damian Wayne so if you
know leave a comment down below and let
me know but I kind of want to see like
Damien Wayne and Cassie sandsmark get
together right like like Wonder I want
to see them like get together because
they just make a great couple because
like they're both just so headstrong and
so independent and it's just really
awesome to see it play out the problem
with this is that Damien actually tries
to convince her to stay behind and
saying that like what we're gonna have
here is we're gonna have a situation
where all these kryptonians that have
previously been confined to the bottled
city of Candor but have now been freed
as a result of deceased they need to be
trained they need to be taught how to
fight all that kind of stuff they need
you to organize and structure them and
teach them battle formations he's kind
of trying to keep her there he's kind of
trying to keep her away from the main
conflict as a whole not in so many words
I mean she even goes as far as to say if
you're trying to spare me from what's
going on he says fear you you're Wonder
Woman I'm asking The Greatest Warrior I
know to protect the entire universe and
her response is really what's the weapon
Damien this thing you and Cyborg have
come up with and where he won't tell her
she says inconveniently I won't be with
you to see it and that's where he kind
of plays this role and he was like does
I mean do you really believe that I
don't want you beside me I really really
do but but you need to be here to
basically teach people how to fight the
superhero numbers have been drastically
reduced so on and so forth he's trying
to keep her there now he's doing it out
of love and he's doing it out of concern
but again Cassie is one of the most
amazing female characters in DC she's
pissed because she wants to fight she
wants to be there in this battle and be
a part of it she doesn't want to be kept
and so it's one of the coolest things
about her character I love the role that
Cassie sandsmark plays here and Tom
Taylor does a great job writing her
right then of course you get this really
really cool moment right because again
this is all kind of leading up to this
big thing you have this cool note where
Jonathan Kent meets with Damian only for
us to find out that it's Damian's
birthday and so where Jonathan says if
you're really gonna go through what this
plan with like the whole life force and
all that kind of stuff and you're
leading the charge then you need to
represent life right so what he does is
he gives him a new Batman suit that is
totally draped and white and it looks
dope like we'll see what it looks like
when he's wearing it because he looks
amazing in an all-white bat suit oh my
God right now here's a funny thing Tom
Taylor's not pulling this out of nowhere
Jeff Johns did this during his Green
Lantern run there was a point where
Batman became the White Lantern which is
basically like initially started with
Kyle Raynor and Kyle Rayner became space
Jesus but like being a wide Lantern is
what happens when you master all the
other lantern rings and then just kind
of Usher yourself into a higher level of
power now for Damien he hasn't achieved
that level of power it's really more
just a ceremonial Garb if we're being
honest with ourselves right that's
really more what this represents but
he's kind of wearing this outfit as a
representation of the life force itself
so like the good versus the evil light
versus dark that kind of thing and so
once they're all basically kind of tied
into war world and then they in turn
shut down all their hearts and enter
through the Doom tube and into the realm
of Erebus we get what is quite likely
one of the most amazing depictions of a
character in the history of DC Comics I
love the way this guy looks why I just
love the way this guy appears he looks
absolutely awesome and so when you have
Aries and you have the black racer who
appear year before erebos he pays
attention to them right and he says Ares
and the black racer such little things
when there is no one left to fight a war
when there's nothing living to die there
will still be Darkness I gotta say man
it's one of the most intimidating
statements that I think I've seen like a
god-like primordial being make in comics
it's dope and so they immediately go on
the attack now what's funny about this
is Tom Taylor kind of leans into the
idea that they're basically ants
throwing little sticks at a human being
that it doesn't make any difference at
all right like Oliver Queen's got like
The Arrow of Apollo along with a bow
right you have like the the heroes who
are launching an attack against Erebus
where they're literally tearing them
open right like cutting a hole in him
but that's kind of the benefit while Tom
Taylor leans into it and almost makes it
appear a little comedic right in the
sense that it's like what are they
really going to do against this guy
that's the overall point the fact that
he wouldn't pay any attention to them
because he considers them so
insignificant that's their weapon that's
their benefit because how do him open
and then forcing war world inside that's
when everything changes because what
happens here is that cyborg tapping into
his own memories right like accessing
his own systems to ensure the plan goes
through realizes the life force is no
longer in him again remember the life
force was instilled inside cyborg which
is how they were able to synthesize a
cure for the anti-life virus in the
first place and make everybody normal
again but what Damian Wayne realize is
that at some point in the past that
Bruce Wayne his father he says he was a
paranoid man and you were bonded to
apocalyptian technology right Bruce
didn't just hide a Tracker in cyborg he
hacked Cyborg's entire system years ago
and left control with Damian and so
Damien says I had a theory the anti-life
virus left out of your mind I need the
opposite and I found it in you I found
the life equation I extracted it and I
erased it from all of your system now it
only exists in me this is a sacrifice
it's what Damian Wayne is doing he's
literally taken the life equation from
cyborg imbued it with himself with the
intention of entering into Erebus
through war world and then in turn
detonating and wiping out aerobos but at
the same time basically creating a whole
new universe in the process it's amazing
like it's one of the most crazy things
to happen with Damien and so where
cyborg realizes there's no way to stop
him and Damien basically teleports out
before cyborg can do anything in turn
Cyborg joins the rest of the forces and
when they ask him where's Damien at his
response is Damien isn't coming now
initially Darkseid believes that like
the weapon failed and if it did they've
got minutes to get out of this entire
realm of Erebus before they're either
destroyed by him or converted into dead
beings as a result of just being in his
realm but the response here of cyborg is
no the weapon did not falter the weapon
is Damien he's taken the life equation
into himself he intends to travel there
and then basically destroy Erebus in the
process and so Damien does have a few
kind of momentary goodbye guys
specifically talking to Oliver Queen not
the most important thing but it is a bit
of a cool moment here because in turn
Ares the god of war is seemingly
destroyed and then when Damien teleports
inside of Erebus
Erebus starts talking to him right he
refers to him as mortal and then he says
like arabos I was wondering when I'd
hear from you and Airbus responds this
will destroy you too and the response of
Damien is not really I'll just become
something else and so where araba says
I'm willing to bargain the response of
Damien is for your existence no you took
my father you took my brothers you've
hurt my friends and you took so much
from our world from our universe and
when Erebus asks what do you want from
me the response of Damien is the most
Damian Wayne response ever he says
nothing you pissed me off there will be
no bargain this will just be your end
and it's the most Damian Wayne thing
ever now here's what's so cool about
this right the sacrifice of Damian Wayne
here only really has significance to you
if you're familiar familiar with the
history of his character in DC if you're
not really familiar with the history and
the story of Damien to a degree it's
kind of lost on you but Damien in a lot
of ways just killed he was death
incarnate he would kill indiscriminately
in fact one of the first stories where
he appeared he killed a guy who was a
thief he cut his head off because any
and all crimes need to be paid for with
death right a person has to die for any
crime that they commit so to be a person
raised with such an extreme view right
such a black and white and binary view
of life and death Crime and Punishment
coming to a person or becoming a person
that's willing to sacrifice their life
to save a universe is a complete and
total 180 for his character and so what
makes this really cool is Jonathan Kim
steps in right now this story we can
largely kind of assume the history
between Jonathan and Damian is very much
the same even during their younger years
right the super Sons the teenage
superhero team or at least the young kid
superhero team which by the way if
you've never read super Sons one of the
most fun stories stories ever in the
history of DC Comics it was amazing it
was just it was so fun it was a blast
but what they realized is there's no way
for them to extract Damien alive it's
not going to happen in order for Erebus
to die Damien has to die as well so
Jonathan chooses to stay behind now his
father won't let him right like like
Superman does not want Jonathan to stay
there but the response of Alfred as the
Specter is I will get him out Clark
right I will extract uh Jonathan in time
for him to survive the destruction of
this universe but it's just this amazing
moment where literally Alfred and
Jonathan and Damien are just sitting
together the three of them are just
together and just talking and it's an
incredibly beautiful moment because
Jonathan and Damian are best friends and
that that Damien is the last son that
Alfred really has right like he viewed
Batman as a son he viewed Damien as a
son or potentially a grandson but he was
basically family and so with the death
of Damien Alfred will officially lose
the last remaining member of his family
but they have to let him do it they have
to let him make this sacrifice it's so
beautiful the way it was done because
Damien says if I told you what I was
doing you never would have let me go
through with it and the response to
Jonathan is no I wouldn't I was right
you were a great Batman and the response
of Damien is thank you John and then he
explodes right he detonates and so when
Erebus is basically killed in this
massive explosion Alfred gets Jonathan
out of there they get through a portal
right they get back to the real world
itself and then in turn Alfred has this
kind of inner monologue where he says I
visit sometimes the cosmos Damien made I
Glide past its new Sons and I walk over
its cooling planets I had no idea how
much apparent would sacrifice for a
child not until I had my own did I
understand what I would give up for them
what I would do if any harm came to them
how deeply I could miss them my bats my
sons my whole universe it is this just
beautiful ending to what is one of the
darkest stories that DC did but I loved
it oh my God so this is the end of of
deceased guys this is the conclusion of
the story and I think it's probably one
of the greatest stories DC's done I
wouldn't even say the last five years
I'd say the last 10 years let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace